The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, let's start.
So last time we started thinking
about phase transitions.
We said that a simple
example obtained
by taking a piece of
magnet such as iron, nickel
and seeing what happens as
a function of temperature.
And there's a phase transition
between a paramagnet
at high temperature
and a ferromagnet
at low temperatures.
This transition takes place
at a characteristic Tc.
And a nice way to describe what
was happening thermodynamically
was to also look at the space
that included a magnetic field.
And then it was clear
that various thermodynamic
properties had a singularity,
had a discontinuity at the line
h equals to 0 for all T
less than or equal to Tc.
Then we saw that if we looked at
characteristic isotherms going
from high temperatures
going to low temperatures
where there was a
discontinuity, we more or less
had to conclude by
continuity that the one that
goes along Tc, the magnetization
as a function of field,
has to come and hug the
axis at 90 degree angle
corresponding to having
infinite susceptibility.
We also said that once you
have infinite susceptibility,
you can pretty much
conclude that you
are going to have long-range
correlations across the sample.
So that if you make
a fluctuation here,
the influence is going to be
felt at large distances away.
OK?
So given with that
piece of knowledge,
we said what we can
do is to basically do
some kind of averaging.
I can take pieces of the sample.
And at each piece,
I can find locally
what the magnetization
is and have this field
m as a function of x that
varies from one point
to another point.
Presumably, close to this point
either below or above, this m
fluctuates across the
sample over large distances
and is typically small.
So then we use those
pieces of information
to proceed as follows.
We said all thermodynamic
properties of the system
can in principle be obtained by
looking at a kind of partition
function or Gibbs partition
function that depends
on temperature, let's say,
which is obtained by tracing
the Hamiltonian that governs all
microscopic degrees of freedom
that describe this system.
The electrons, their spins,
nuclei, all kinds of things.
Now naturally, this I cannot do.
But I can focus on this
magnetization field close to Tc
and say that each
configuration of magnetization
has some kind of a weight.
And in principle,
what I can do is
I can subdivide
all configurations
of microscopic
degrees of freedom
that are consistent with a
particular macroscopic weight.
Macroscopic field m of x.
And hence, in principle
compute what that weight is.
The analog of tracing over
all degrees of freedom
would now become
integrating over
all configurations
of this magnetization
that I indicate
through this symbol
of functional integration
over all configurations.
Now, clearly I can
no more obtain this
than I can do the
original trace.
So what did we do?
We said I can guess what
this is going to look like.
Because in the
absence of the field,
it's a function that
has rotational symmetry.
So what I can do is I can write
the log of that probability
as something.
So far I haven't done anything.
I made the assumption
that I can write it
as an integral over
space of some kind
of a density at each point.
So that was this kind of
quasi-locality assumption.
And then I would
write anything that
comes to my mind
that is consistent
with rotational symmetry.
Now, since m is small in
the vicinity of this point,
it makes sense that I
should make something
like a Taylor expansion.
So the Taylor expansion will
start not with a linear term,
which violates rotational
symmetry, but something
that is quadratic.
And I can add any
even power such as m
to the fourth and
higher order terms.
And I can add all kinds of
gradients that are consistent,
again, with rotational symmetry.
And the first of those terms
is gradient of m squared.
And there are many more.
Of course, there can be
an overall constant term.
Maybe I will write it out front.
Insert a Z regular, which means
that you-- in the process,
you have all kinds of
other degrees of freedom
that are not reflected
in the magnetization.
You're going to have
phonon degrees of freedom.
So there will be a
contribution from the phonons
to the partition
function of the system.
We are not interested
in any of those things.
We are interested in what
becomes singular over here.
And the reason I write
that as Z regular
is because it's presumably some
benign function of temperature
as I pass through this point.
So it is, indeed, a
function of temperature.
It is also worth
emphasizing that not only is
this parameter that appears
outside representing
all kinds of other
degrees of freedom
a function of temperature,
that these phenomenological
parameters that
I introduced here
are also functions
of temperature.
Because the microscopic
weight, the true Hamiltonian,
is the one that is
scaled by 1 over kt.
Just because of
analogy, I sometimes
call this combination of what is
happening here beta H or minus
beta H as appearing
in the exponent.
But that, by no means, indicates
that the coefficient here
are scaling inversely
with temperature
like the true
microscopic coordinates.
Because in order to do
this coarse graining,
I have to integrate over a lot
of different configurations.
So there is energy
associated with this.
There is entropy
There is all kinds
of complicated things
that go into this--
these parameters.
So that's important to remember.
Finally, if I slightly
go away from here just
to explore the vicinity of
having a finite magnetic field,
then I can work in
the ensemble where
I have added the field here.
And the weight here
will be modified
by an amount that is h dot m.
So what is occurring here is
this Landau-Ginzburg model
that I right now
introduced in the context
of magnetic systems.
But very shortly,
I will introduce
this in the context
of super-fluidity.
I can go back to
the original example
that we started with the
liquid gas phenomena,
replace m with some kind
of a density difference,
and then it would indicate
a phase transition
of the liquid gas system.
So it is supposed
to be very general,
applicable to a lot of things
because it is constructed
on the basis of nothing other
than symmetry principles.
But at the cost of having
no knowledge of how
these phenomenological
parameters depend
on the microscopics of the
system-- on temperature.
Clearly, for example, even
in the context of magnet,
I would construct the same
theory for iron, nickel,
cobalt, et cetera.
But presumably
these coefficients
will be very different from one
system as opposed to the other.
All right, so that's supposed to
be, as far as we are concerned,
sufficient to figure
out what is going
on in the vicinity
of this transition.
Maybe I should emphasize
one more thing,
which is that I said that
after all what we are trying
to figure out is the nature of
singularities in free energy,
in phase diagrams, et cetera.
Yet, when I wrote
this, I insisted
on making an
analytical expansion.
And the reason making an
analytical expansion here
is justified is because
to get this expansion,
I summed over
degrees of freedom--
I averaged degrees of freedom
over some finite piece
of my system.
Maybe I took a 100 by
100 by 100 Angstrom cubed
block of material and averaged
the magnetization of spins
in that area, et cetera.
And the idea that we also
encountered last semester
is that as long
as you are dealing
with a finite system,
all of the manipulations
that you are doing involve
analytic functions such as e
to the minus beta H applied to
a finite number of integrations.
And you simply cannot get
a singularity out of such
a process.
So the averaging process that
goes in this coarse graining
must give you
analytical functions.
That's not the origin
of the singularity.
The origin of the
singularity must
come from taking the size
of the system, the volume
of this piece of iron,
essentially to infinity.
That's what gives
us the singularity.
Also, because of that I expect
that at the end of the day,
this Z of T and h
that I calculate
will be something
that is proportional
to volume or something
like that in the exponent.
That is, I will have
something like e
to the-- from this component
minus V some beta f regular.
And actually, let me just
forget about the beta
and just write it as some
other function regular.
It's an extensive quantity.
And the result of
this integration
of all of the field
configurations
should give me
another contribution
that is proportional to volume.
And hopefully, all of the
singularities that I expect
will come from this piece.
And I am going to expect those
singularities to arise only
in the limit where
V becomes large.
Now, last semester
we saw a trick
that allowed us
to do integrations
when the final
answer was extensive.
It was the saddle point result.
Basically, we said that as we
span the integration range,
there is a part that corresponds
to extremizing whatever you are
integrating that gives
you overwhelmingly
larger weight than any other
part of the integration.
So let's try to,
without justification--
and we'll correct this--
apply that same principle
of a saddle point approximation
to the functional integration
that we are doing over here.
That is, rather than
integrating over all functions,
let's find the extremum.
Where is this
function maximized,
the integrand is maximized?
So what I need to do is to
find maximum of exponent.
So what is happening over here.
I am going to make one
further statement here
before I do that, which is
that this term, the thing that
is proportional
to gradient of m,
has something to do
with the way spins
know about their neighborhood.
And if I am looking at
something that is ferromagnet,
the tendency is for neighbors
to be in the same direction.
That's how
ferromagnetism emerges.
And that corresponds to
having a K that is positive.
So that helps me
a lot in finding
the extremum of the
function because it
means that the extremum
will occur when m of x
is uniform across the system.
Any variations in m of x will
give you a cost from that
and will reduce the probability.
So with K positive, I know
that the optimal solution
is going to correspond
to a uniform value
across the system.
What is this uniform value?
If I put a uniform
value, first of all,
the integration will
simply give me the volume.
That's good because that's
what I expect over here.
So at the end of the
day, what do I get?
I will get that F singular is,
in fact, the minimum of psi
of m where psi of m is obtained
by simply evaluating what
is in the integrand at
a uniform value of m.
t over 2 m squared
mu m to the fourth.
Potentially higher orders,
but no K. The K disappeared.
Minus h m.
Actually, I kind of expect
also that the uniform solution,
if I put a magnetic field, will
point along the magnetic field.
If there's an up field,
the uniform solution
will be along the field.
If it's 0, then I don't know.
If it is down field, it
will be the opposite.
So it makes sense that
if I have a field,
the uniform magnetization
should point
along it, which means that over
here this dot product is really
just h times m.
So I reduced the complexity
of the problem subject
to this saddle
point approximation
to just minimizing
some function.
Now, it is important
to note, since I
was talking about analyticities,
and singularities, and things
like that, that whereas the
function that is appearing here
as psi of m as we discussed
is completely analytical,
the operation of finding
the minimum of a function
is something that
introduces non-analyticity.
So that's how we are going
to get that structure that we
have over there.
Let's explicitly
show how that occurs.
So I'm going to show you
the shape of this function
in the space that is
spanned by the parameters
that I have here,
which are t and h.
We will come to u later on.
But for the time being, since I
want to show things in a plane,
let's stick with t and h.
So first of all, let's look at
the regime where t is positive.
So this is 0.
To the right is t is positive.
Right on the axis
when h equals to 0,
the function is m squared plus
m to the fourth, et cetera.
The coefficient of m
squared is positive.
So basically, right on
this axis the function
is like a parabola.
So what I am plotting here are
different forms of psi of m.
So this is m squared
is a parabola.
If I go further
out, m to the fourth
is something to worry about.
But if I'm really looking
at case where the emerging
magnetization is
small, I can stick just
with the lowest order
term in the expansion.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Are we
plotting h or psi?
The axis label was h.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So there is a
two-parameter plane t h.
At each plant in this parameter
plane, I can plot what psi of m
looks like.
Unfortunately, I can't
bring it out of the plane,
so I am going to put it
in the two dimensions.
So this is why I wrote
psi of m with green
to distinguish it with
the h that is in white.
So this is supposed to
be right on the axis.
If I go up on the axis, what
would psi of m look like?
So now I have a term
that is positive h m.
So it starts
linearly to go down,
and then the m squared
term takes over.
So now the minimum is over here.
Whereas, right on
the axis-- again,
by symmetry-- the
minimum was at 0.
If I go and look at what
happens at the other side
when h is negative,
then the slope
is in the opposite direction.
So the function kind
of looks like this.
And the minimum has
shifted over here.
So if I were to plot
now what the minimum m
bar is as a function
of the field h,
as I scan from some positive t--
from h positive to h negative,
what we have is that
this sequence then
corresponds to a curve
in which, essentially, m
is proportional to h.
Something like this.
So this is for t
that is positive.
Now, what happens
if I try to draw
these same curves for
t that is negative?
Let's stick first again to
the analog of this curve,
but now for h equal to 0.
So for h equals to
0, in plotting psi
if m, whereas previously
the parabola had
the positive coefficient,
now the parabola
has a negative coefficient.
So it kind of looks like this.
Now, one of the things that I
know for sure in my system--
again, mathematics does not tell
us that, physics tells us that.
That I have a
piece of iron and I
know that the typical
configurations of magnetization
are some small number.
So if the mathematics says that
I have a function such as this,
it is wrong because it would
say that the extremum would
go towards infinity.
But that's where the
u-term comes into play.
So I need now to have a
u-term with a positive sign
to ensure that the function
does not have an extremum that
goes to minus plus infinity.
Physics tells us
that the function
that I get if t is negative
should have a positive u.
Now, what happens if
we take this curve
and go to h positive?
Well, now again, like
we did over here,
I start to shift it
in one direction.
In particular, what I find is
that the minimum to the left
goes up and the minimum
to the right goes down.
What did I do?
Drew this poorly.
I start to go like this.
So now there is a well-defined
minimum over here.
If I go to negative fields,
I will get the opposite
Where I have this.
So now if I follow a
path that corresponds
to these t negative
structures, what do I get?
What I get is that the extremum
is at some positive value.
So this is for t
that is negative.
As I scan h from
positive values,
I am tracking this minimum.
But that minimum ends
up over here at 0.
So basically, I come to here.
Whereas, if I come
from the negative side,
I am basically following
the opposite curve.
And then I have a
discontinuity exactly at the h
equals [INAUDIBLE].
Again, by continuity if I
am exactly at t equals to 0,
the function is kind of--
rather than the parabola
is m to the fourth, and
a little bit of thought
convinces you that the shape
of the curve kind of looks
like this.
We will quantify what that shape
is shortly for t equals to 0.
So what did we do?
We were able to reproduce
exactly the structure
of the isotherms
that we are getting
for the case of the ferromagnet
from this simple theory.
In order to just match exactly
this with what is going on
with iron or nickel,
what do I have to do?
I just have to ensure
that this parameter t goes
to 0 at Tc of whatever
the material is.
Now, remember that I
said that my t is really
a function of temperature.
So I can certainly
make an expansion of it
around any point.
Let's see the Tc
of the material.
So what I require is that the
first term in that expansion
has to be 0.
Then I will have something
that is linear in T, and then
quadratic in T minus Tc
squared and so forth.
So there is one condition
that I have to impose,
that that function
of t-- which again,
by all of the arguments
that I mentioned,
completely has to be an analytic
function of temperature.
Hence, expandable
in a Taylor series.
The 0 to order term in that
Taylor series has to be 0.
What else?
That I can expand
any other function.
U of t is u0 plus u1 T
minus Tc and so forth.
K of t is k0 plus k1 T
And I don't really care about
any of these coefficients.
The only things that
I know are the signs.
a has to be positive
because the high temperature
side corresponds to paramagnet.
u0 has to be positive because
I require the stability
types of things
that I mentioned.
And k0 has to be
positive because I
want to have this kind of
ferromagnetic behavior.
Apart from that, I
really don't know much.
So the Landau-Ginzburg
Hamiltonian with one condition
reproduces the
phenomenology of the magnet
and all the other
phase transitions,
which as one of you-- I think
it was David-- was pointing out
to me, is very much like dealing
with a branch cut singularity
in the mathematical
sense along this axis
terminating at that point.
So this branch cut
singularity is a consequence
of this minimization
procedure of a purely
analytical function.
And the statement of
universality at this level
is that pick any
analytical function
and do this minimization.
You will always get the
same mathematical branch cut
that we will now explain
in terms of the exponents.
So we said that experimentally
these phase transitions,
their universality
was characterized
by looking at singularities
of various quantities
and looking at the exponent,
the functional forms.
So let's first look
at the magnetization.
So if I do the extremization
of this, what do I do?
I have to have d psi by dm
equals to 0. d psi by dm
is tm bar plus 4u m
bar cubed minus h.
For h equals to 0 along
the symmetry axis,
then I have two solutions.
Because that I can write
as t plus 4u m bar squared
times m bar equals to 0.
If I state at that
equation, I immediately
see that the possible
solutions are m bar is 0.
And that's really
the only solution
that I have for any
t that is positive.
While for t negative, in
addition to the solution at 0,
which is clearly unphysical
because it corresponds
to a maximum and not a minimum,
I have solutions at minus
plus square root
of minus t over 4u.
And so if I were to
plot this magnetization
as a function of
t, essentially I
have a kind of coexistence curve
because I have nothing above
and below I have a
square root singularity.
So this corresponds to the
exponent beta being 1/2.
So that's the prediction
[? from each. ?]
What about the shape of this
green curve, the isotherm
that you have at t equals to Tc?
Well, t equals to
Tc, in our language,
corresponds to
small t equals to 0,
which means that I have to look
at the equation 4u m bar cubed
equal to h or m bar
is proportional to--
well, let's write it.
h over 4u to the power of 1/3.
So this green curve that
comes with infinite slope
corresponds to a
1/3 singularity.
The exponent delta was defined
to be the inverse of this,
so this corresponds to having
an exponent delta that is 3.
We had behavior of
susceptibility characterized
by another set of exponent.
Now, the susceptibility,
quite generally,
is the response of
the magnetization
if you change the field.
And typically, we were
interested in the limit where
we measured a response if
you are just at h equals to 0
and then you put
a little bit more.
The equation that we have
that relates h and m bar
is simply that h equals to
tm bar plus 4u m bar cubed.
Rather than taking
dm by dh, let me
evaluate its inverse,
which is dh by dm.
dh by dm is t plus
12u m bar squared.
And so this inverse
susceptibility,
if I am for t positive,
m bar is also 0.
So the inverse
susceptibility is t.
If I am for t negative, m bar
squared is minus t over 4u.
I put a minus t over 4u here.
And it becomes t minus 3t.
So it becomes minus 2t.
Again, nicely positive.
Response functions
have to be positive.
If I were to plot this
susceptibility, therefore
as a function of
temperature, or t
that is related to T
minus Tc, what do I get?
I will get a divergence that is
inverse of 1 over T minus Tc--
on both sides.
So basically, I get
something like this.
And we said that the divergence
of the susceptibility we
characterize by exponent gamma.
And as I had promised,
we explicitly
see that, in this
case, the gammas
on both sides of the transition
are the same and equal
to unity.
The inverse vanishes linearly,
so the susceptibility
diverges with unit exponent.
But actually, we
are making-- we can
make an additional
statement here
that experimentalists
can go and check
that I hadn't told you before.
Now, you see in all
of these other cases
the only thing that I can
say is universal side is
the functional form.
This is where the
exponent beta came from.
But the amplitude of
what is happening there,
or the amplitude of
what is happening here,
these are things that depend
on you and all of these things
that I have no idea about.
Similarly here,
because I don't know
what the relationship between
t minus Tc and the parameter t
is, it involves this number
a that I don't know of.
But one thing that I notice
is that the ratio of these two
things is a pure number.
So I say, OK, what you
have is if you measure
the susceptibility on the
two sides of the transition,
you will see amplitudes.
And then T minus
Tc absolute value
to minus gamma plus
or gamma minus.
I have told you that
the gammas are the same.
I don't know what
the amplitudes are,
but I can tell for sure that
the ratio of amplitudes--
if this is the theory
that describes things--
is a pure number of 2.
So that's another thing
that you can go and say
the experimentalists can check.
They can check the
divergence, and then
see that the amplitude
ratio is a universal object.
OK, there's one other response
function that I had mentioned.
There was the
exponent alpha that
came from the heat capacity.
So how do I calculate
heat capacity?
So the heat capacity, which
is a function of temperature,
let's focus only in the
case where h equals to 0,
is obtained by taking a
temperature derivative
of the internal
energy of the system.
Now, the energy,
on the other hand,
is obtained by taking a d by
d beta of log of the partition
function.
Now, I have all of my answers in
terms of these parameters t, u,
et cetera.
But I know that to
lowest order, there
is a linear relationship
between small t
and the real
temperature that I have
to put into these expressions.
So in particular, I
can do the following.
I can say that
something like d by dT d
by d beta, where
beta is 1 over kt,
is something
approximately when you
look at the linear regime that
is close to Tc of the order--
1 over beta is going
to be kb t squared.
And then I would have d by
dT, and then another d by dT.
I have to evaluate
all of these things
eventually in the vicinity
of the critical point.
Everything else is going
to be a correction.
So to lowest order,
I will do that.
And then I note that this
is related-- derivatives
between temperature
and small t are
related through a factor of a.
So I do this and I
put a squared up here.
Doesn't matter.
The only reason I do that is
because through the process
that we have described here, I
get an idea for what log of Z
is.
So in particular,
log of Z has a part
that comes from all of the
regular degrees of freedom
and a part that comes from
this additional minimization
that we are doing.
So we have a minus V times the
minimum of the function, which
is t over 2 m bar squared
plus u m bar to the fourth
when evaluated at h equals to 0.
So this is log Z, which
is some regular function
of temperature, and hence t.
Why is this part singular?
Because for t that
is positive, m is 0.
So this is going to give me
0 contribution for t that
is positive.
Whereas, for t
that is negative, I
have to substitute
the value of m bar
squared as I found above,
which is minus t over 4u.
So I will get t over 2
times minus t over 4u.
So that's going to give me
minus t squared over 8u.
Here I will have-- once I
substitute that formula,
plus t squared over 16u.
The overall thing would be
minus t squared over 16u.
So I have to take two
derivatives of this function.
You can see that the
function will give me
0 above for t positive and it
will give me a constant for t
negative.
So if I were to plot two
derivatives of this function
as T or T minus Tc is varied.
Well, there is a
background part that
comes from all the other
degrees of freedom.
So there is basically some kind
of behavior you would have had
normally.
What we find is that
above t positive,
that normal behavior is the
only thing that you have.
And when you are below, taking
two derivatives of this,
something is added to this.
So basically, the prediction
is that the heat capacity
of the system as a
function of temperature
should have a jump
discontinuity.
Now, I said that in
a number of cases
we see that the heat
capacity actually diverges
and we introduce
then exponent alpha
to parametrize that divergence.
Since we don't have
this divergence,
people have resorted
to indicating this
with alpha equals to 0.
But since alpha equals
to 0 is ambiguous,
putting a discontinuity
in addition
to be precise about
what is happening.
So the predictions of
the saddle point method
applied to this field
theory are the set
of exponents and
functional forms
beta equals to 1/2, gamma
as being 1, et cetera.
A nice set of predictions.
And of course, the
test is, do they agree?
It turns out that there is
one and only one case where
you do the experiments and you
get these precise exponents.
And that's something
like a superconductor.
And the picture that
I showed you last time
for the gas, et
cetera, corresponds
to totally different
set of exponents.
So at this point, we have to
face one of two alternatives.
One, the starting
point is wrong.
We put everything we could
think of in the starting point.
Maybe we forget something,
but it seems OK.
The other is, maybe we didn't
do the analysis right when
we did the saddle
point approximation.
And we'll gradually
build the case
that that is, indeed, the
case and that we should treat
the problem in a
slightly better fashion.
Any questions?
OK.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just to remind me,
the saddle point approximation
was saying m was continuous,
a continuous number
across the substrate?
PROFESSOR: The saddle
point approximation
is to evaluate the functional
integral, which corresponds
to looking at all
configurations,
replacing that integration
with the value of the integrand
at the point that
is most probable.
In this case, the most probable
point was the uniform case.
But maybe in some other case,
the most probable configuration
would be something else.
The saddle point is to replace
the entire functional integral
with just one value
of the integral.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So your second claims
that analysis is probably wrong
somewhere.
It is most likely
when we are trying
to compute the energy of the
system from all of field m
and we just assumed
something incorrectly,
and that's why we get
incorrect exponents?
PROFESSOR: No.
My claim is that up to the place
that I say Landau-Ginzburg,
I have been extremely general.
It may be that I
missed something,
but I will convince you
that that's not the case.
Then the line below that says
saddle point approximation.
My claim is that that's
where the error came.
AUDIENCE: Also, we can do
a similar kind of analysis
for liquid gas transition
in critical [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And then,
how would it be
reasonable to assume
uniform density?
Because I guess the
whole point of behavior--
PROFESSOR: We did exactly
that approximation in 8.3.3.3.
I wrote down some theory for
the liquid gas transition
out of which came the
van der Waals equation.
AUDIENCE: Yes.
PROFESSOR: And the
assumption for that
was that the density in the
grand canonical ensemble,
in the grand canonical
ensemble was uniform.
So that you either
got the density
for the liquid or the
density for the gas.
But I made there the saddle
point approximation also.
I assumed that there was a
uniform density that was--
AUDIENCE: OK.
So was just likely to
be the point where--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --something breaks up.
So before doing that,
let me point out
to something interesting
that happened.
And it's just a
matter of terminology.
Note that we constructed the
Landau-Ginzburg Hamiltonian
for h equals to 0
on the basis that we
should have rotational symmetry.
Nonetheless, even for h
equals to 0, what we find
are solutions where the
magnetization is pointing
in one direction or the other.
So it is possible to
have the state that
emerges as a result of a
weight that has some symmetry
to not have that symmetry.
So the symmetry is
spontaneously broken
and the direction in
space is selected.
Now, of course,
what that means is
that if you apply the
rotation operation to one
of these ground
states, then you will
generate another equally
good ground state.
You can take everything that
is pointed along the z-axis
and make them all
point along the x-axis.
That's an equally
good ground state.
So essentially, you have a
manifold of possible states.
And making a change
from one state deforming
to another ground state does
not cost you any energy.
So one consequence of that
is that slow deformations
should cost little energy.
What do I mean by that?
So let's imagine that
I start with a state
where after I minimize, I find
that all of my magnetizations
are pointing up.
Now, as I said, I could rotate
everybody into this direction
and the formation of my
state would cost no energy.
That's a uniform deformation.
What if I took a deformation
that is very slow?
So I gradually rotate from
one to the other state.
Then in the limit where the
wavelength of this deformation
becomes of the order of
the size of your system,
you should have no energy cost.
And it kind of makes sense
that in the limit where
you have long wavelengths, you
should have little energy cost.
So you should have slow
wavelength, no energy
distortions or modes,
called Goldstone modes.
But you can only have this for
a broken continuous symmetry
such as what I have
depicted there,
where all orientations
are equally likely.
But if I had the
liquid gas system,
the density was either above
average or below average.
If I had uniaxial
magnet, the spin
would be either
pointing up or down.
Then I can't deform slowly
from one to the other.
So for discrete symmetries,
you don't have these modes.
For continuous symmetries,
you have these modes.
And actually, we've already
seen one set of those modes.
These were the phonons.
When in the first lecture
I was constructing
this theory of
elasticity, I said
if we take the whole deformation
and move it uniformity,
there is no cost.
And then we were
able, based on that,
to conclude that long wavelength
phonons have little cost.
And we wrote their dispersion,
relation, et cetera.
So phonons are an example
of Goldstone modes.
These kinds of rotations of
spins in a magnet-- magnons
are another example
of these modes.
But something else that we said,
therefore in the first lecture,
is something that we should
start to think about.
Which is that we said that
because these modes exist
and they have so little
energy cost, if I
am at some finite temperature,
I will be able to excite them.
So I know for sure that if
I'm at finite temperature,
there are at least
these fluctuations that
are going on in my system.
And maybe in lieu
of that, I should
be wary of assuming that only
the state where everything
is uniform is the thing
that is contributing.
What about the fluctuations?
So let's think about
these fluctuations that
are easiest and most
easily generated
and look at their thermal
excitations and consequences
for the phase in
phase transition.
And let's do that in the
context of superfluid.
So we saw the problem
of super fluidity
towards the end of 8.3.3.3.
You had helium that
was an ordinary liquid.
We cooled it below 2.8
degrees and suddenly it
became a new form of matter
that has this ability
to flow through
capillaries, et cetera.
And we pointed
out that there was
some kind of quite
likely quantum origin
to that because of
the similarities
that it showed to
Bose-Einstein condensation.
And basically, it
was in this context
that Landau introduced
something like this The theory
that we write down
where he chose as order
parameter as the analog of the
m of x that we have over there,
a complex function psi of x.
And very roughly,
you can regard this--
and again, this is very
rough-- as overlap of wave
function with the
ground state at position
x in some coarse-grained sense.
Now, anything
quantum mechanical we
saw has an amplitude
and a phase.
So this is actually a
number plus a phase.
Or if you like, it has a real
part and an imaginary part.
And there is no way that we
know anything about the phase.
The phase is not
an unobservable.
So the probability that
when we scan the system
we have identified some psi of
x that the probability should
depend on the phase
is meaningless.
It's not an observable.
So this functional
should only depend
on things like
absolute value of psi.
If, like Landau, we assume
that it is a local form,
then the kinds of
terms that we can write
are absolute value of psi
squared, absolute value of psi
to the fourth power.
And the tendency for the order
to expand across the system you
would put through a term such
as gradient of psi squared.
Now, for the case
of the superfluid,
there is no physical field
that corresponds to the h.
That just you don't
have that field.
You can convince yourself
that if you write psi
to be psi 1 plus psi 2, i psi
2-- real and imaginary part.
And put that in this formula,
that corresponds exactly
to the theory that we
wrote over there as long
as we choose a
two-component magnetization.
So these two theories
are identical.
Now, if I look at this
system for t negative
and try to find a
minimum of the functional
that I have over
there, then the shape
of the function functional
psi-- poor choice of notation.
Psi both being the wave
function as well as the function
that I have to extremize.
But let's stick with it.
It has a minimum that
goes along a circuit.
So basically, take
this picture that we
have over here that corresponds
to essentially one direction
and rotate it.
And what you will get
is what is sometimes
called the wine bottle type
of shape, or the Mexican hat
potential, or whatever.
But essentially,
it means that there
is a ring of possible
ground states.
So the minimum
occurs for psi of x
having some particular
magnitude which corresponds
to the location of
this ring-- how far
away it is from the center.
And that will be given by
the square root of t formula
that we have up there.
But then there is a
phase that is something
that you don't know.
Now, let's ask the question.
Suppose I allow
this phase to vary
from one part of the sample
to another part of the sample.
So that's the analog
of this slow distortion
that I was making up there.
So essentially, as I go
from one part of the sample
to another part of
the sample, I slowly
move around this bottom
of this with potential.
And I ask, what is the cost
of this distortion that I
impose on the system?
If I calculate beta H for psi
bar e the i theta x, what I get
is whatever I have
put over here,
such as this function
which minimizes the-- which
is the location of the minimum.
But because of the variation
in theta that I have allowed,
there is a cost.
So let's write that as beta
H0 plus this additional cost.
The additional cost
comes from this term.
If I simply put psi bar in
to the i theta over there,
I will get an
integral d dx k psi
bar squared over 2
gradient of theta squared.
So there is an
additional energy cost.
This is very similar
to the energy cost
that we had for phonons.
Because if I Fourier
transform, you
can see that I get
a k squared just
like we got for the
case of phonons.
And just like for
the case of phonons,
I expect that at some
finite temperature,
these kinds of modes
are thermally excited.
So in reality, I expect that if
I'm at some finite temperature,
this phase will fluctuate
across my system.
And maybe I should note
that whereas I'm here
thinking in terms of
thermal fluctuations,
by appropriate boundary
conditions one can establish
a gradient of theta that is
uniform across the system.
And that actually corresponds
to a superfluid flow.
So the case of a
superfluid flow can
be regarded by having
a gradient of theta
being proportional to
velocity, and then this
is something like
the kinetic energy.
But that's a different story.
Let's just stick with
the fact that this
is the cost of making
these distortions.
And I want to know, what's
the probability of having
one of these distorted shapes?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Question.
When you're introducing the
psi as another parameter
and you call it overlap of
[INAUDIBLE] what is boundaries
and what values this sort
of parameter can take?
So I basically wonder if we
have this Mexican hat-shaped
potential with minima on
the ring of radius at 1,
can the value of potential-- of
the other parameter principally
be further than that?
PROFESSOR: OK.
So again, here we are trying
to phenomenologically explain
an observation that there is a
transition between a case where
there is no super
fluidity and right when
a certain small amount
of super fluidity
has been established
in the system.
The question that you asked
over here is legitimate,
but you could have asked
it also for the case
of the magnetization.
So you could have
said, why not to have
that potential with the
minimum somewhere else?
But that does not
explain the phenomena
that we are trying to explain.
The phenomena that we
are trying to explain
is the observation that
I go from having nothing
to having a little
bit of something.
And I choose the
mathematical form
that is capable of
describing that.
AUDIENCE: My question
basically was,
when we were talking about
magnetization, if you take
a piece of metal,
you can magnetize it
from 0 to a pretty large value.
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: If we are interested
in something not too large--
PROFESSOR: No.
AUDIENCE: And as I
say, [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: What is your scale?
What is very large?
For a magnet, there is a
maximum magnetization--
AUDIENCE: In this case, I mean
that spontaneous magnetization
for a magnet would be
lower than saturation, no?
PROFESSOR: What is saturation?
AUDIENCE: When all spins
are same direction.
PROFESSOR: OK.
So you have a microscopic
picture in mind.
Now, the place
that we are is far
from that saturation
magnetization.
Similarly, in this
case, presumably
if I go to 0 temperature,
there is some uniformity.
And if I call this an overlap,
the maximum of it will be 1.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
But basically, I just
don't understand--
what is overlap
of wave function?
PROFESSOR: Well,
that's why I didn't
want to go into that detail.
But basically, the overlap
of two wave functions
would be the psi
1 star psi 2 of x.
And if you are thinking
about the ground state,
let's say that I have
normalized this function
to have a maximum of 1.
The point is that
what that maximum is,
is folded into all of these
parameters-- a, u, et cetera--
and is pretty irrelevant to
the nature of the transition.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: OK?
So the probability of a
particular configuration
of theta across the system
is given by this formula.
I can unpack that a
little bit better just
like we did for
the case of phonons
by writing theta in
terms of Fourier modes.
e to the i q dot x theta of
q, which for the time being,
I assume I have discretized
appropriate values of q.
I choose this normalization
root V in this context.
If I substitute
that over here, what
I find is that beta H as a
function of the collection
of theta q's is,
again, some beta H0,
which is not important.
I put gradient of theta.
Once I do gradient
of theta, you can
see that I get a factor of iq.
I will have two of
them, so the answer
is going to be
proportional to q squared.
Let's call this combination
k psi bar squared k bar
so that I don't have to
write it again and again.
k bar over 2.
And then theta of q squared.
OK?
So the probability of some
particular combination
of these Fourier amplitudes
is proportional to exponential
of this.
And therefore, a
product of independent
Gaussian-distributed quantities.
q squared.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: When you plug in
your summation of your-- well,
your Fourier series
into the gradient
and then you square
that, why don't you
get interactions between the
different Fourier amplitudes?
PROFESSOR: OK, let's
do it explicitly.
I have integral d dx gradient
of theta gradient of theta.
Gradient of theta
is iq sum-- OK.
Is i sum over q q e to the
i q dot x theta tilde of q.
And I have to repeat that twice.
So I have i sum over q prime
q prime into the i q prime dot
x theta tilde of q prime.
So basically, this
went into that.
This went into that.
OK?
So I have a sum over
q, sum over q prime,
and an integral over x.
What is the integral over x of
e to the i q plus q prime dot x?
It is 0, unless q and
q prime add up to 0.
This is delta function.
So you put it there.
Only one sum survives.
Actually, I had introduced
the normalizations that
were root V. The normalizations
get rid of this factor of V.
That's why I had normalized
it with the root V.
And I will get one
factor of q remaining.
Since q prime is minus q iq
iq prime becomes q squared.
And then I have theta
tilde of q theta tilde
of minus q, which gives me this.
So each mode is independently
distributed according
to a Gaussian, which
immediately tells me
the average of theta of
q tilde is, of course, 0.
Let's be careful and put the
tildes all over the place.
While the average of
theta tilde of q squared
is 1 over k bar q squared.
Again, all that says is that as
you go to long wavelength modes
and q goes to 0,
the fluctuations
become larger because the
energy cost is smaller.
OK, so that's understandable.
But now, let's look at what
is happening in real space.
I pick two points,
x and x prime.
And I ask, how do
the fluctuations
vary from one point
to another point?
So I'm interested in theta x.
Let's say minus theta.
Let's calculate the
following first,
theta of x, theta of x prime
just because the algebra
is slightly easier.
Now, theta of x I can write
in terms of theta tilde of q.
So this becomes sum over q
q prime e to the iq dot x
e to the iq prime dot x prime.
There is a factor
of 1 over V that
comes from the
normalization I chose.
And then the average
of theta tilde
of q theta tilde of q prime.
But we just established
that the different modes
are independent of each other.
So basically, this gives
me a delta function
that forces q and q
prime to add up to 0.
If they do add up to 0,
the expectation that I get
is 1 over k bar q squared.
And so what I find is
that this becomes related
to a sum over q 1 over
V e to the iq dot x
minus x prime divided
by k bar q squared.
If I go to the continuum
limit where the sum over
q I replace with
an integral over q,
then I have to introduce
the density of states.
And so then I find that
theta of x theta of x
prime is 1 over k
bar integral d dq
2 pi to the d the Fourier
transform of 1 over q squared.
Now, the Fourier transform
of 1 over q squared
is something that
appears all over physics.
So let's give it a name.
So we're going to call the
integral d dq 2 pi to the d
e to the iq dot x
divided by q squared.
And let's put a minus
sign in front of that.
And I'll give it the name
the Coulomb potential
in d dimensional space.
And for those of you
who haven't seen this,
the reason this is
the Coulomb potential
is because if I
take two derivatives
and construct the Laplacian
of that function--
so I take two derivative
with respect to x here,
the two derivatives will
go inside the integral.
And what they do
is they bring down
two factors of iq
divided by q squared.
The minus sign disappears,
q squared over q squared
goes to 1.
Fourier transform of e to the iq
x is simply the delta function.
So this Cd of x is the potential
that would emerge from a unit
charge at the origin
at a distance x.
So again, for those who have
forgotten this or not seen it,
let's calculate it explicitly
using Gauss' theorem.
The potential due
to a unit charge
is going to be spherically
symmetric, so it's only
a function of the
magnitude of x.
It doesn't depend
on the orientation.
And Gauss' law states that
the integral of Laplacian
over volume is the same as
the integral of the analog
of the electric field, which is
the gradient over the surface.
So I have the surface
integral of gradient.
Now, for the case that
we are dealing with,
the left-hand side Laplacian
is a delta function.
So when we integrate that over
the sphere, I simply get 1.
So this gives me 1.
What do I get on
the right-hand side?
It's just like the flux
of the electric field
that you have calculated.
It is the magnitude
of the electric field
times the surface area.
And I am doing this
generally in d dimensions.
So the surface
area in d dimension
grows like x to the d minus 1.
And then there is a factor
such as 2 pi, 4 pi, et cetera,
which is the solid
angle that you
would have to put
in d dimensions.
And to remind you, the
solid angle in d dimensions
is 2 pi to the d over 2 d
over 2 minus 1 factorial.
So the magnitude of
this derivative dC
by dx following
from that is simply
1 divided by x to the d
minus 1, or x to the 1
minus d divided by Sd.
So this is generalizing
how you would calculate
Gauss' law in three dimensions.
So now I just integrate that and
I find that the d dimensional
Coulomb potential is
x to the 2 minus d
divided by 2 minus d Sd.
And of course, there could be
some constant of integration.
So it reproduces the familiar 1
over x law in three dimensions.
But the thing that
is important to note
is how much this
Coulomb potential
depends on dimensions.
It determines these angle--
angle fluctuation correlations.
And typically, here
in this context
we want to know something
about large distances.
If I make a fluctuation
here, how far away
is the influence of
that fluctuation felt?
So I would be interested
in the limit of this
when the separation is
large-- goes to infinity.
And we can see that
the answer very much
depends on the dimensions.
So we find that for d
that is greater than 2,
like the Coulomb potential
in three dimensions,
you basically go to a constant.
While in d less than
2, it is something
that grows as a
function of distance
as x to the 2 minus
d 2 minus d Sd.
And actually, write at
the borderline dimension
of d equals to 2, it also
grows at large distances.
If you do the
integration correctly,
you will find that it is 1 over
2 pi log x over some distance
or [INAUDIBLE].
Now, what you are really
interested-- actually,
this thing that I wrote down
is not particularly meaningful.
The thing that you
are interested in
is what I had
originally written,
which is that if I look at the
angle that I have at x and then
I go far away-- because
the angel itself is not
an observable, but
angle differences are.
So the average of this
quantity will be 0.
But there will be
some variance to it,
so I can look at this quantity.
And that quantity--
I can expand this--
is twice the average of theta
at some particular location.
Presumably, it doesn't matter
which location I look at.
So it's the variance locally
that you have in the angles.
And then minus twice theta
of x theta of x prime,
which is the quantity that
I calculated for you above.
So all I need to do is to take
the Coulomb potential that I
calculated, multiply
it by a factor of 2,
divide by a factor of
k bar that I basically
indicated as part
of the definition.
So this object is going
to be 2 x to the 2
minus d divided by
k bar 2 minus d Sd.
And actually, the reason
I do this is because now I
can indicate the overall
constant as follows.
Remember that all of our
statistical field theories
are obtained by averaging.
And I shouldn't believe
any of these formulas
when I look at very
short wavelengths.
So I shouldn't really
believe any answer
that I got from those formulas
when the points x prime and x
come too close to each other.
So there is something of the
order of a lattice spacing,
averaging distance, et
cetera, that I'll call a.
And by the time I get to a,
I expect that my fluctuations
vanish because that's
the distance over which
I'm doing the average.
So I manage to get rid of
whatever this constant is
by substituting [INAUDIBLE] with
the scale over which I expect
my theory to cease to be valid.
But again, what I
find is that if I
look at the fluctuation between
two points at large distances,
if I am in dimensions
greater than 2,
this thing eventually
goes to a constant.
Which means that if I'm
in three dimensions,
the fluctuation in phase between
one place and another place
are not necessarily small or
large because I don't know what
the magnitude of
this constant is,
but they are not
getting bigger as I
go further and further along.
Whereas, no matter what I
do in d that is less than
or equal to 2, this thing
at large distances blows up.
So I thought that I
had a system where
I had broken spontaneous
symmetry and all of my spins,
all of my phases were
pointing in one direction.
But I see that when I put
these fluctuations, no matter
how small I make the amplitude,
the amplitude doesn't matter.
If I go to far enough
distances, fluctuations
will tell me that I don't know
what the phase is from here
to here because it has gone
over many multiples of 2 pi,
so that it has become divergent.
So what that really means is
that because of fluctuations,
you cannot have
long-range order.
So destroy continuous
long-range order
in dimensions that are
less than or equal to 2.
This is called the
Mermin-Wagner theorem.
So you shouldn't have any,
for example, super fluidity,
magnetization, anything in two
dimensions of one dimension.
If you go to long
enough, you will
see that fluctuations
have destroyed your order.
So we can see already how
important fluctuations are.
This d equal to 2 is called
the lower critical dimension.
It is this phenomena of
symmetry breaking, ordering,
phase transition,
et cetera, that we
are discussing for
continuous systems--
for continuous symmetry
breaking can only
exist in three dimensions
but not in two dimensions.
We'll see that for
discrete symmetries,
you can have ordering in
two dimensions, but not one
dimensions.
So there, the lower
critical dimension is 1.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: And does
this hold for any n?
This example you were doing--
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: --it just
has two components.
PROFESSOR: Any n. n equals
to 2, 3, 4, anything.
We'll see later on, towards
the end of the course,
that there is a slight proviso
for the case of n equals to 2,
but that we'll leave for later.